you know Chris Leben yes the Crippler
the Crippler yeah he was Ivan touch him
for a while but he was a we used to hang
out back in the day and I remember one
time I was doing shows in Hawaii and
from there yeah and he came to the shows
and I was there for a week and I was
like hey let's uh you know let's drink a
party and he's like no I'm good
so every day I like we were drinking a
party and he was like now so find the
last tag that's my last day are you
really not gonna like rage any ghosts
all right you want me to know in the
rage and I go yeah he just ya know he
goes okay here we go oh boy yeah Bravo
yeah so he's trying to stay so haribol
so you start doing sake bombs I mean
this is like 12 years ago start doing
sake bombs and then all the second
floodgates open we're just hammered we
go to Dave & Buster's he chokes my
friend out in the middle of Dave &
Buster's he just loses it oh my god
chokes him out my buddies just frothing
at the mouth on the ground
oh my we're all like oh my god and then
it just it just literally escalated to
the point where like I beat him a pop a
shot he started throwing like leg kicks
then he got me like in a leg show cold
in the cab cab driver pulled over it
just it was really I I hung out with him
in upstate Washington and I was doing
the kick and he was there and he was
doing an appearance and his head like
this yeah it's got the widest head and a
triangular his body the triangle
shoulders he's and his fingers and hands
are so big he sits horrifying he said
and and he got he's so nice he's such a
nice man sweetheart but he was a little
he was a little out he got he started
same thing he started to rage and you
could see that that that's one of his
demons yeah Oh peace I hope he's sober
because he's a I think he is yeah it's
like coach now do you know at the UFC
gym good he's a [ __ ] good guy so yeah
so the next day I was like - look at how
he's a he's got an awesome looking
fellow there look at him oh you don't
need to do what he did to me during that
a whole excursion he goes punched me in
the face oh my god no man I'm good and
he goes no punch me in the face hard as
you can I go I'm good dude I go that's
really weird
and he goes here's the deal if you don't
punch me in the face in five seconds I'm
gonna punch you in the face
now it's just like whap like right away
oh my god god that's so where where do
you punch him though in the cheek or
something I don't even know I punched
some like meaty area where like it just
absorbed my hand and then it push it
back out it's got such a wide face it's
like hi you go from one eye to the other
hello Craig did you ever see the fighted
with Bisping in London and he just stood
there and put his hands down he was just
like to punch me oh my no I never saw oh
my gosh dude he just dropped his hand
dropped his arms he had some rough dos
yeah yeah I'm gonna take a beating man
yeah listen so vyd was having none of it
but those innocence fight was it really
in the UFC the game Chris Leben he lit
him up like Christmas tree oh that is
very horrible thing you know yeah
Christmas in high school his prime
nobody's oh no one knew that no it was
in his prime no one knew no one's very
high yeah
moths came from prior we knew he's a
badass but he wasn't like the spider
right that's a solid photo that's great
if you're bit say god that was meant by
those man for my first set in New York
moving in size that oh my god is right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]